[Music]
everyone's having babies you know it's
it's crazy Kristin Cavallari weighing in
on the hills Laguna Beach baby boo
et caught up with the star at the launch
party for her jewelry line uncommon
Jane's everyone from the hills is either
pregnant or had a baby both of the
Alex's just had babies so it's really
cool to see everyone in the next chapter
of their life on the hillside Lauren
Conrad a Whitney Port and Heidi Montag
will all become first-time moms this
year Heidi's been asking me lots of baby
questions yeah I'm so excited for her I
know she's been wanting a baby for a
while so it's very cool what was the
first question that Heidi asked you
about being a mommy when she told you
she was having a baby well she's so
funny she just asked my input on names I
was like Heidi this is your baby
why do you god I like that's what you
were gonna make your baby so it would
it's sweet you know and then joy I sent
her a whole list of things that I loved
as a as a mom with you know the the
first six months or so and and it's cool
because I remember being a first-time
mom I didn't really have anyone I could
turn to was the first one out of all my
friends so I love that I've been able to
be there for Heidi and Audrina you know
Audrina reached out a lot when she was
pregnant it's really cool that they feel
comfortable enough to come to me and
that they look to me for those kind of
you know that kind of advice a lot of my
girlfriends are becoming first-time moms
and they always say I just I don't even
know where to start
I know I know that's how I was you know
it can be overwhelming but it's those
cliche things of sleep when the baby is
sleeping and just I think the biggest
thing is knowing that everything is a
phase so knowing that everything will
pass this first six months are hard
they're really hard and just know that
it will be over you will be sleeping
again you know it gets easier
you